I was more willing to engage lock
antlers when I was young I don't think
people are gonna change their minds
anymore I don't want to be the carnival
barker on some freak show people were
split we'll find out where we go which
way at each election in between it's
going to be contentious at age 66 I
don't want to wake up every day and
fight with people that's stuff they're
not gonna change their mind on anyway
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report reminder everybody subscribed to
Rubin report calm if you want to get all
our videos early and totally ad-free and
more importantly joining me today is a
stand-up comic and host of dennis miller
plus one on the RT network as well as
the dennis miller option podcast dennis
miller i've already said your name three
times
what's up rubes welcome to the rubin
report beautiful pad here man I'm trying
to read you can tell a man by his books
and how am i doing his tchotchkes I see
you're a Karlin fan which I find in your
little steven pinker NBA I think your
detractors would say this indicates
you're moving right word towards John
Birch participation have the math Center
down an odd confluence between South
America and or the globe I should say
South America and Africa where it's
split up and I have a theory it looks
like they were together at one point yes
if split apart and obviously the west
coast of Africa with Ivory Coast Liberia
is the most contentious place in the
planet and I think that's a sudden hard
drive tremble from way back when where a
guy went out into his yard and Liberia
once and said honey what's this crack
and then two weeks later I've often
wondered how Pangaea split yeah I'm
giving you a little something of
everything here cuz we got lefties we
got righties look I got an American flag
in the control and I love over there I
always love to have a map in my studio
to feel yeah so you got two shows you've
done a bajillion things I said to you
right before I'm not even gonna use
notes I try not to really look at my
notes when I talk to most guests anyway
I thought I just sit down and see what
happens you kind of just need to be
wound up and then you go right well you
know what but I I tell you as I get
older I need to be
wound up and let go less I just listen
it's contentious now I was at more of oh
I don't want to use the entire term
firebrand but I was more willing to
engage lock antlers when I was young I
don't think people are gonna change
their minds anymore
I don't want to be the carnival barker
on some freak show people wear split
we'll find out where we go which way at
each election in between it's gonna be
contentious at age 66 I don't want to
wake up every day and fight with people
that's stuff they're not gonna change
their mind on anyway so when I get going
I like to put on a good show
you know your your Spanky and our gang
let's put on a show but I don't need the
I don't need to get going as much
anymore so you're like an evolved
political satirist or something I just I
used to dig the game when you could
budge somebody an angstrom I didn't need
them to come over I never thought did
you get to talk to somebody and they
were gonna desert their core beliefs and
come over your way but they at least you
could see the mulling I think Mullings
gone I could see Moon's gone
it's just now people nobodies
everybody's dug in and then man I'm
trying over here no I appreciate but
like I said I don't know you're in your
40s right I would probably fought the
flop more then but I'm telling you why
you seem like just the time we talked
before and you seem like smart enough
got that somewhere down the road I can't
see you fighting it into the barn seem
to be a lone little beautiful family in
the picture out here got a great place
you're kicking ass and taking names
career wise yeah you should do it now
but at some point the the harvest is
you're gonna do I'm into getting up and
reading taking a hike having a good meal
appreciating the fact I married the most
beautiful witty charming girl I ever met
during my son's watching some baseball
and then reading as I fall out to sleep
is that a tough thing though for a comic
I have to face no for me what do you
think for most comics that's like you
almost like a fear that you fear the
okayness cuz you won't have the fuel
it's a convenient it's a job yeah I'm I
was never very I don't be a show
business is some sword from the stone
moment where you're annoying
that job I grew up in Pittsburgh and my
job what I was good at was I would think
jokes up and then I tried to give those
jokes to somebody else to do and then I
found I didn't have the ego for that
once I saw somebody do a joke I thought
up on The Tonight Show on Carson
laughing I'm not built for this I better
become the unlikely conduit but I've
never thought of myself as the silver
surfer he competed yeah and so no I
don't you know I don't have any moment
pangs right I go I wish I was in the
frame it never was like that when I was
in the frame
were you always political because I
think I should get that job on SNL you
have to become political yeah so you
weren't political before I used to be a
prop comic I remember working with the
like yeah I was never quite carat opium
but I got an actual word I think that's
rally in the dictionary now that's
depressing
I I did props when I first started
because I thought that visually that way
but then I remember I couldn't fit the
props in the overhead I had slight props
and then I thought you know I'm not
gonna wait a half an hour at a right for
some inflatable seat I could put on my
head and say it last for 30 I ditched
that on that started writing jokes like
I said sold a couple of other comedians
saw them do them and score with them and
thought I've got to be the guy so I like
I said it's very I didn't have a
whoosh-whoosh thing about stand-up I
remember thinking okay this is a good
career kind of a decision so when you
get the Weekend Update situation the SNL
situation then it's sort of like it was
political what what year did you start
an SNL somewhere nice so we're somewhere
what I mean though I'm not doing this
deliberately yeah just I remember I was
maybe like 89 or something cuz I'm
trying to remember cuz you on SNL that
that class was like my formative comedy
year class so I was like twelve thirteen
around then and I think I think maybe
like 89 or something like that well some
people think of themselves as comedic
visionaries I choose to think of
ourselves as assuring kids through
puberty
we were they if you were 12 yeah that's
all we were there was a 15 minutes off
from jerk and
yeah but you guys didn't see I made it
out okay but I remember I was in
Baltimore and I had auditioned for SNL
maybe a month before and then I remember
they picked the cast USA Today had
picture of them I wasn't in and I was
still in Baltimore and I was so tough at
that point because on your way up you
have to be tough I didn't stand up with
New York 12 years I was a gladiator and
I remember seeing that picture I didn't
have a crestfallen thing I think I came
close to that all right keep going then
I was up doing Letterman
and somebody came into the Letterman
dressing room and said listen Loren
Michaels wants to see you on 8:00 or no
17 where his office was and I said Jesus
I knew something he's not calling me
down to revisit me to tell me why it
yeah you're really not getting it but
I'm thinking maybe I get a shot on it as
a comedian or something like Stephen
Wright would come on yam once in a while
so I went down I knew it was gonna be
something good but then I walked in I
remember it's one of those moments that
stick in your head Lawrence it's that
the other thing he's got one of those
green dome two glasses a lights on his
desk you know that gives it that Arthur
Conan Doyle feel he's got the quarter
glasses on reading scripts or something
and over his shoulders the Empire State
Building and I remember it being like
red white and blue and wasn't for the
July or anything but he looked somebody
goes st. Dennis Miller I got hey Loren
he says I would you like to do Weekend
Update and I said I'd like that a lot
well I'll see you tomorrow around 11:00
I said all right sir I walked out and I
remember thinking I'm not a big drinker
but I remember saying I'm gonna go get
four fingers of something brown rocks
and knock that stand because this is
pivotal and that was magical I don't
want to act like I'm sitting over a
butan I'm talking about stand-up I was
kind of step by step Maginot Line move
it six inches fall back four move it
four but when that happened I remember
thinking all right take some mental
Polaroids here don't be blase about this
because that's its own defense mechanism
this is a big deal Chevy Chase did this
you're gonna do it now enjoy it until
you either become a success or get
whacked so I did enjoy it a long way I
took all those moments and you know the
first time you sit in that seat
yeah yeah count you dad I just thought
all right I might go out but I'm going
out on my shield here so even though you
weren't purely political they pegged you
for that were you is that what is that
is that what you wanted did you want to
do more I wanted any hook yeah I think
I'm not a character guy I used to try to
stay out of the SNL sketches because you
know when you're with geniuses Carvey's
comedic genius Lovitz the sketch wise a
genius Phil I mean the only guy I never
thought I'd see a guy like Danny and
Phil got in the realm with him and I
always thought wow this is a serious
play Mike Myers comes in so you've got
four leads there it could kill the ball
I'm the fifth guy in a sketch I'm the
bartender saying here's your gimlet and
yet I got to be there blocking it for
three and a half hours so I used to go
around that say to writers when they
wrote me and I'd said I want to be like
the D H I want to pick a rock song
they're having the weighted bat downtown
will come out and you know hit the ball
for ten minutes and by the end you had
that right yeah it was a groovy job and
I used to I probably been around a dozen
sketches over the years and they were
ones where I thought oh this is good I
should stay in this because I want to
see I want to see this when I get older
I it's a wonderful life the next chapter
you know you know when something was
gonna be a big hit but by and large I
was really happy to have just Weekend
Update if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlists
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell